>> Hi, my name is Susan Dumais.
I'm the Assistant Director of
Microsoft's Research AI lab.
I'm here today with
Michael Jordan,
who is one of the world
renowned computer scientists
and statisticians in the world.
He's been at Microsoft earlier
today as part of
our faculty summit,
whose topic this year is
systems and the future
disruptions,
that will be enabled by
progress and systems.
One of the topics obviously
in thinking about
the next generation of systems
is where AI meets systems.
So, there have been
sessions on AI for systems,
and systems for AI.
Mike has been incredibly
involved in some of
those discussions.
So, Michael is a Pehong Chen
Distinguished Professor
in EECS at Berkeley.
He's also on the faculty in
the Statistics
Department and part of
a couple of really interesting
multidisciplinary labs.
One on algorithms
machines and people,
and the other on BAIR's,
Berkeley AI Research or
something like that.
Michael has a background
in psychology,
statistics, and
cognitive science.
So, he brings a really broad
perspective to problems.
One of the things that I
think is most impressive,
Mike, about your background is,
that you've won a tremendous
number of publications,
tremendous influence in the areas
of computer science,
and statistics.
But your awards come
from a broad set
of organizations and fields.
So, clearly, you're
a fellow of the ACM,
but you're also a fellow of
the American Statistical
Association,
the Cognitive Science Society,
the Bayesian Society.
I want to start
the discussion today
by having you reflect a little
bit on your graduate work.
You were at UCSD
with Dave Rumelhart,
and others in the mid-80s,
at maybe the second
renaissance of
the Artificial
Intelligence's area,
working in parallel and
distributed systems.
I still have my two volumes
of the PDP books with
the three-and-a-half inch
floppy disks in the back.
Can you say a little bit about,
maybe the intellectual
environment at the time?
This field was really nascent,
as well as how it's
influenced some of
your subsequent thinking about
problems of intelligence
and computation?
>> Sure. First of all it's
a pleasure to be here.
I've known Susan for
a number of years.
I've been given lots of
interviews in
the last few years as
the interest in
the fields picked up.
It's the first time
I've given interview
to someone who probably knows
more than I know about,
half of the topics we're
going to be talking about,
and usually you have to
be explaining things.
Yes.
So, I've moved around a lot in
my life and it's not directed,
it's partly random walk.
It's just because of curiosity,
and also a feeling that
not any one person,
or any one field has
got all the answers.
It's by synthesizing
various people's
perspectives and ideas.
I was thinking
about this earlier.
How I might explain that?
So, one of my friends, Yana Khan,
refers to me as the Miles Davis
of machine learning,
not the Michael Jordan,
because he was an example,
someone who moved throughout
his career just try new things.
Another anecdote was
when I was a kid,
my grandparents took me to
Europe for the first time.
We went to Sweden,
and I loved it.
At some point apparently,
I was lost, They said
they thought I was lost.
They couldn't find me for half a
day and finally they found me.
I was with a bunch
of Swedish children
because I've decided
I'd become Swedish.
Because it just that, I should
just do one thing in my life,
I should become a Swedish child.
So, I think that I was,
first of all, I had
a bad American education.
So, I was lucky that I arrived
at age 20, I knew nothing.
So, I could sort of met
my own ideas about what to work
on and I had,
I think like most of that age,
read some philosophy and
found that interesting,
and I was lucky enough
to be in an era
where there had been
analytic philosophy.
So Bertrand Russell had written
an autobiography, and
very presciently,
he was talking about
the mind and the
scientific perspective on
it and how logic
and mathematics and all
arose out of the mind,
and just felt right
to me that there
was something deeper about that.
He had it with a sense of
humor and a feeling that there's
something new going to
happen in this area.
So, that helped to influence me.
Then just by hooking what
was available to me,
I was a programmer at San Diego.
It was largely because
of experimental psychology that
I found my first interest.
I remember a work by people
like Roger Shepherd,
where you talk about
mental rotation,
and just the idea you could
probe into a system
that was very,
very complicated and still gleam
things about it from the outside.
It was fascinating.
I was just impressed
by the skills
that people to be
able to do that.
I think psychology
though was just so,
so hard, where probing into
a massively complex system.
There was nothing else like it.
Even think about the economic
system of New York City.
It's nothing like
close to the brain,
and think about probing
that from the from
the atmosphere while
you're looking at
the lights or the emissions.
It's just where we're at.
So, I still feel
that that is the
the field of the future,
of the next several
hundred years.
I think it'll take that long to
start to really get
insights into it.
Since I have unfortunately
short lifetime,
I thought I'd better move
on to faster moving fields.
I think kind of luckily
is part of that,
I'd also studied some statistics
because you had to
analyze your data.
I started to appreciate
not just the use of
statistics and calculating
P values and
an analysis variance,
but the 300-year-old tradition of
inferential thinking that
was embodied in the ideas,
and where were with
those principles
coming from and
what do they mean,
and surely that has
something to do with
how humans approach the world.
So, I was already
thinking that what's
most interesting about
humans is their ability
to abstract something
about the world,
and then their ability to deal
with all the uncertainty,
and to make plans and
that sort of thing.
So, I was less interested in
the low levels perception
in motion processing.
Even though I did
some work on it,
it just didn't feel like where
my heart was going to be.
So, Dave Rumelhart, I'm
glad you mentioned him
was my first real
adviser in life.
He was a brilliant man,
genial really, died
young unfortunately.
But he set the stage
for much of the work
that's going on now,
and he also, I don't think
would be happy with
just a narrow perspective.
He really wanted to
think broadly about
all the tools and all the
ways of thinking.
I really got
that perspective also.
He, when I first
arrived, there was
interest in
schematic networks and
schematics of natural
language and perception.
I continue to think those are
some of the real problems,
perception and abstraction,
and then how do you
think about semantics.
I don't think we're
there yet. I don't
think we understand them.
We're very, very primitive in
our understanding of those.
So, then he turned
into neural nets and
back propagation is
this famous algorithm,
although it's really
just the chain rule,
and it's kind of control
theory side to it and all that,
and it's reinvented a
thousands of times.
But he really is
the person in the neural net
field who kind
of worked on it for,
he reinvented it.
For a couple of years
that was his main focus.
His office was
right next to mine,
and he come in every day
telling me about
the cool new aspects of what he
was trying to do and he
finally got the algorithm,
and he tried it out
on all the Minsky
papper problems and
it really did those,
and he was super
excited about it.
So, his excitement,
his intellectual
breadth and his blend,
there was no disciplinary
boundaries for Dave.
Experimental psychology,
linguistics, mathematics,
statistics was all fair game
for his intellectual adventures.
So I've taken away some of that.
>> You talked about
descending into fields,
and sucking up information
from them and growing,
but you also influence
of all those fields.
When I looked back
at your early work,
your thesis was on
learning representations
for sequential
performance essentially
using recurrent neural networks
for some simple cognitive tasks.
One of the things
that I remember,
it may have been one of
your first NIPS papers
was work on adaptive
mixtures of experts,
and that's something that
we'll come back to at the end
because I know you have
lots of important
perspectives on some of
the limitations of
current deep models.
But those cover are couple
of really important topics.
One is looking not
just at snapshots
of the world but it's
sequences of behavior,
and the other is thinking not
about isolated competencies but
multiple experts coming together.
It's amazing as I
look back at this
earlier today that that
work is 30 years old now,
but it really
foreshadowed some of
the things that
were seeing today.
>> Yes. Thank you for
these great questions.
I'm not used to getting
such great questions.
So, it was an interesting
sequential performance
because the neural
nets of the day
didn't do much sequentiality.
It was all about matrices
and factorization and so on.
But, I was pretty interesting
in the context of
the psychological phenomena
which was speech.
That's one of the most
important sequential acts
we do is to speak.
But, if you look at in detail,
all of our articulator
is the tongue
and the lips and
the vocal chords.
All are actually staggered
and they are asynchronous.
They're doing
all things in parallel.
So, the feature vector of
the speech apparatus has
all the components
working in parallel.
Nonetheless, there's an overall
sequence reality to that.
So, it was very much to me,
how do you model that? How
do you conceive of that?
It felt like things
like neural nets were
relevant because they
were naturally parallel.
>> Right.
>> If we can imbue them
with a bit of sequential,
we can get the best
of both worlds.
We could see
a little bit of that.
So, actually that was
what I was interested in.
I didn't really innovate,
personally I don't
believe very much in
the neural network sphere
in that particular line of
work just using neural nets but
noticing that if you train
them at a particular
very sequential way,
they wanted to fill
in and therefore do
the core articulation or
the parallelism that you
would see in real data.
Again, that's kind of thing
Dave really liked.
He liked that line of work that
the neural net did
something that was not
part of the training data,
but it was reasonably
good description
of something that
humans were doing.
The other line of
work in fact has gone
further for me which
is just thinking
about modularity and abstraction
but also thinking
about when you have
multiple entities that have to
cooperate or compete
and it's leading.
So, my recent work to
much more economics perspectives
and thinking about huge numbers
of entities that have
to work together not
just a small handful like
and are mixtures work.
>> Okay, great. I
want to pop from
your early days and it's
interesting because you've come
back to some of these ideas with
several decades of
advances in learning,
in data, and in infrastructure.
But before I do that,
I want to just talk
a little bit about some of
the fundamental algorithmic and
theoretical advances you've made.
Your work on
variational methods for
approximate inference
in graphical models is
huge or LDA paper.
I think it's been cited
over 25,000 times.
The work on spectral clustering
on popularizing EM algorithms.
This has really changed
the practice of
machine learning and
statistics and in many ways.
Do you have a gem that has not,
in one of your
favorite innovations
and breakthroughs
says it is not as
well-recognized as some other
very popular and
widely cited ones?
>> I'm always the most fun
of my most recent work.
>> Okay.
>> Because the older work,
it just seems obvious in
this respect and probably
even obvious even in a day.
But, now recent work I think
has gone the furthest.
It's has become more
theoretical over
time as the field has
become more empirical,
things need to be
a complimentary more
theoretical perspective.
So, lots of work on
optimization and
sampling relationships and
returning to variation themes.
So, variational I learned
about it from physics,
but I love the history
of mathematical ideas and
variations, of course,
it goes back to
variations in calculus
and before and it says you turn
a problem into
an optimization problem.
So, you may be adjust
your problems to integrate or
your problem is to write
down a different
equation and you say,
"Well, how can I
formulate that as
a solution to an
optimization problem?"
The optimization
problem could be in
a space of say
probability distribution.
So, your output can
be a distribution.
But, now you say, "Well,
that's a solution
to an optimization problem."
Having done so, you get brand
new mathematical perspective
and particularly you can
perturb the optimization problem
that will then move
the solution a little bit,
and the perturbation can
lead you to insight.
But, it also can lead
you to new algorithms.
So, there is a variational
perspectives to
all sort of things,
calculating an eigenvector.
An eigenvector as ax equals
lambda x but it's also
a relay ratio where you optimize
a certain ratio and
that is an eigenvector.
It's a variational characterization
eigenvector formula.
In that way, you
get new algorithms.
So, the physicists
were onto this.
So, people had
borrowed the idea of
Mean-Field methods from
physics into neural nets.
So, there was lots of these
Mean-Field are deterministic.
I found that very
provocative even started
reading deeper and as often was
the case they had
20 years of history and
a push that much further and they
started to call that
variational methods.
So, we borrowed I think
the broader perspective and
then brought that into context
with graphical models.
They mainly were studying
lattices and physics things.
So, we said, "Well,
there's an opportunity
to take those same kind
of ideas and bring them
into the much more
structured world of
graphical models and
particular directed graphs."
So, conditional
probabilities rather
than just field models.
So, in some level,
it was just explorations in
the set of ideas that hadn't
quite brought together,
then EMI day also there
hadn't been much work on
doing them with the graphical
model variational things.
So, but that still
goes for to this day.
That line of work I'm actually
still feel is very,
very incomplete.
There's hardly any theory on it.
There's finally starting to
be a little more innovation
algorithmically.
Again, it's picking up again
but these things are a
really long-term projects for
not just me but for
the whole community.
>> You've been doing some work
recently on non-convex
optimization?
>> Yeah.
>> Can you talk a little bit
about that because
a lot of the functions
clearly that
you're trying to
optimize especially in
deep models are not
particularly convex.
>> Well, not just deep models.
So, all kinds of
phased retrieval models,
all kinds of
combinatorial models,
a lot of them are non-convex.
They have a single global
optimum, some of them.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> So, they seem simple but they
have all the saddle points.
The neural nets and I think
that one of the key problems
is they have lots
of saddle points.
I don't think this was
appreciate at least in
my era back when I was
learning neural nets,
but it was all about
the local optima that should
fall into in the simulated
annealing and ways of
getting out of that.
I think it's in the last five
years or so that
it's been realized,
well if there are a few local men
or even a whole lot
there could be
even more saddle points
and what'll happen as
it high dimensions get stuck
next to the saddle points
for indeterminate
amount of time and it
could be even scale
badly in dimensions so that
if in bigger problems,
you'll spend more and more time
around the saddle points
and you will know that because
not just saddle point,
you just feel the learning curve
is flattened out,
and you think you're done,
but you really just have,
you got to escape from
that direction of escape.
So, let me mention Shrijan who's
a student with me
working at Berkeley.
He's a real leader in this area
of saddle point
avoidance and escape.
There is a sequence
of papers where he is
the lead author
that you really dig
into this and try to
get not just rates of
convergence but
dimension dependence.
So, it's kind of pride
in theoretical work.
I think this is not just me
but the rest of our field has
gotten very good at
not just asymptotic rates,
but actually finite sample rates.
Then beyond that, the constant
has dimension dependence and
we're getting the constants.
We're getting sort of
the dimension dependence.
>> Okay.
>> So, that's a theory that
becomes extremely
interesting mathematically
but also very real in
practice and gives this
field a lot of
connections that didn't
exist five or 10 years ago.
So, saddle points are interesting
if you want to avoid them.
Indeed, there's lots of
non-convex optimization
problems too.
But, it is also
interesting if you take
the game from this perspective
or multiple agents.
Where you don't want to
avoid saddle points,
you want to find
the saddle points,
because the saddle points
through the Nash equilibria
or the other kind of equilibria.
So, that's an emerging area
that I'm working on with
students in my group.
There is a literature
about how to go
towards saddle points but
as is often the case, it's
incomplete literature.
It didn't face the modern
constraints that we have.
In particular, if you create
saddle points that
are Nash equilibria,
you'll probably create lots of
other saddle points
that you don't want to
hit just because that's how
mathematics tends to work.
So, there's great open
problems there and
then if you go to
the large scale versions of
these things where you have
not just two agents or 10
but you've got
hundreds of thousands,
it's going to be very, very
interesting and challenging.
So, that's one aspect of
the economics perspective meets
algorithms that I'm
very interested in.
>> Okay. Great, thank you.
Let's try to talk about
a couple of other topics.
So, one is in
the last decade or so,
we've seen just
dramatic advances in
the capabilities of
computational systems
to do things like
understand speech,
to understand aspects of vision,
label objects, generate captions,
to do some aspects of
language understanding
particularly the work
in machine translation
I think has
been really beyond
my expectations,
some work in robotic control
and many of
these innovations have
fueled I think things
that neither of us would
have expected 10 or 15 years ago.
The fact that you can do
real-time analysis of
voice on phones in
noisy environments and get it
right a startling
proportion of the time.
The fact that in
machine translation,
you can translate
from one language to
another in near real-time.
These accomplishments
have fueled a variety of
interesting new
computational capabilities
yet they have a set of
very isolated competencies.
You recently published
an op-ed piece or
thought piece in a medium
on Artificial Intelligence,
the revolution that
hasn't happened
yet that generated a lot of buzz.
Can you reflect on the fact
that there have been
amazing advances yet we're miles
and miles and miles away
from thinking about intelligence
in the same way that
you see in humans or
more interestingly
interacting sets
of humans and
computational elements.
>> Great question again.
So, there's a lot of issues there
that need to be untangled and so
I'll try not to speak too long
but in my op-ed tries
to untangle.
I think that everyone is
lumped too much
into the phrase AI.
One of my the phrases I
was proud about in
the op-ed was that
people are using AI as
an intellectual wildcard.
That when they don't
understand what's
happening or understand
how to solve it,
they say, "AI will do
it or that's AI problem
or whatever."
Most of these systems are
pattern recognition systems
and that's great.
There are lots of patterns in
the world and these things
are pretty good
if you have especially lots of
labels that help you
find those patterns.
I, first of all,
don't think that's
the whole class problems
I'm interested in or many of
us should be interested in.
I think that creating
systems that serve
humans and help us make
our lives safer more
interesting do this
at scale make us able to
interact with other humans
in the world better.
Very few of those have
a lot to do with creating
artificial humans with speech
language vision problems.
They have to do with all kinds
of decision-making at scale,
they have to do with
problems and none of
us evolve to solve.
That our human intelligence isn't
particularly good at and
whereas good decision-making
inferential principles
are going to be needed
to build such systems.
If you think of domains
like commerce or healthcare
or finance or et cetera,
there's just crying
out for here's data,
here's utilities with
large numbers of players.
How do I create something
that will work for people?
So, I don't think that working on
what I called in that article
"human-imitative AI".
The classical aspiration
which is still an aspiration.
I don't think it's necessary
for sufficient for
working on a lot of
these challenges.
So, lumping them all together,
I think is a mistake.
The biggest progress
has been made in areas
like you're talking
about vision and
speech and natural
language and so on.
But the algorithms that are used
for that are not necessarily
the ones that are
going to work for trying to make
100,000 decisions at scale.
So, it is I
think unfortunate to
think that those are
the main problems that industry
should be focusing on.
There's a larger class of
problems they should
be focusing on.
Now, also I do need to push back.
You said the word speech
understanding and
language understanding
and intelligence
may even have come up there.
I don't think these systems and
with all due respect for
my colleagues who are
in those areas are doing
much speech understanding, right?
They're transcribing a way form
into lexical items, right?
Very impressively with
lots of noise and all
that but they don't understand
anything about the speech.
Moreover, the natural
language translation systems
are not understanding
the language at all.
They are taking in
a French sentence and
basically they are
mapping it that string
to an English string.
All right. There's
no understanding
between here and there.
Now, when we look
at the outputs of
these things and the errors
and the kind of
things they could do,
we as humans are able to
sort of read into
them saying, "Wow!
It seemed to understand
something." Well, no.
There was a statistical
thing that it picked
up on and that's not
all it is that's not.
So, our ability to understand
what's happening in
the world to abstract
in particular,
we are miraculous abstractors
and neural nets do a little bit
of abstraction in their feature
finding but they
don't think about
the high-level
multifaceted complex
abstractions humans are.
>> I mean to be fair, a lot
of human capabilities
especially perceptual
capabilities are
based on statistical
regularities of the world.
>> Well, they could be based on
that we don't know if they are.
I mean so think about a squirrel.
I talked about this
in the op-ed too.
But a squirrel is an amazing
perceptual motor system.
It hops among
the trees in ways that
we can even have
hardly imagine, right?
So, it's doing somehow
it's brain has
evolved or maybe learned but
probably not learned a lot.
Probably, a lot of evolution
came into making that
squirrel so good.
So, it's able to do things
that we can hardly fathom.
There are neural nets or
maybe starting to approach
the end of our lifetimes we'll
be able to see a lot
from squirrels.
I would hesitate though
to say squirrel has
a lot of intelligence, all right.
Building such as
a squirrel-like system would
require a vast amount of
intelligence or
human intelligence.
But I hesitate to say
that that system is going
to be one that
embodies what I would
recognize as intelligence
or understanding of
the world or be able to abstract
about it. I think squirrels.
We don't want to limit
what squirrels can do.
They can probably do some
problem-solving and annoying us
with their abilities
in that regard.
But really so,
if you haven't seen
Doug Hofstadter's thing on,
he had an op-ed as well
around the same time I wrote
mine on The Shallowness
of Google Translate,
and I think he does
a pretty good job of saying,
"If you don't have
any semantics at all,
you're just not going
to really be able to
solve natural language
translation."
So, you get a sense that
people think well we got went
from 80 percent to 90 to 95.
Of course, we're going
to be to 99.9 soon
just more hardware or
more data will do it.
That's just is not true in
a domain where it really
requires a rich understanding of
the world around us to
really do what's right.
>> I think it's really
clear that there are
huge limitations to
the competencies
that current systems have.
To get to the next level,
we need to think more
broadly about systems that
have perceptual or low-level
recognition capabilities
as well as more symbolic
deductive reasoning.
>> Well, they may be symbolic
deductive, they may not.
Abstraction is a word
that doesn't have to
be- the idea that we're
having an interview,
that's an abstraction of
what is happening with
all the pixels and all the sound
waves in the room right now.
It's not a low-level abstraction,
it's quite a high-level.
There's many, many kinds
of interviews and many,
many kinds of
situations that all of
us humans really
understand that thing.
I also noticed on the last time
I came here to Microsoft,
I was participating
in an event called
the Disruptive Technology Review.
>> That's right.
>> I know what disruption
means but it now has
all kinds of other meanings
that people have
associated with it.
It's become a good thing,
first of all,
and all of us understand that and
disruptive technology really
can be parsed in two ways.
It could be a disruptive
technology review.
We're reviewing
the disruptive technology
or it could be a disruptive
technology review.
All right. We'll get that and
it's interesting even
funny and amusing.
You probably didn't
think about it.
You probably picked one of those
two but they're both there.
Our computers are very,
very far from the ability
to understand things of
that sense and have humor
about them and use
them in creative ways.
Do that not just for
the words disruptive technology
but for about every other word
that we can think of.
Even the word saying
that bad is now
good and stuff like
that as humans really,
really are flexible with
the ability to use that and
that's not even talking
about how we interact with
the real world and
the abstractions that
are involved there.
So, these aren't problems
that one can't work on,
but it's just decades
and it's not that
we get enough big datasets and
enough hardware and we get it.
I just think there's
a little there's
a lot of naivete to
tell you about that.
My colleagues who work
on those problems in
natural language don't have that
naivete for the most part but
a lot of the PR agents
for sort of the companies
that are doing
this do have
that naivete and that's
being spread out too
far into the community.
>> Do you have any reflections
on what's needed to get
to some of the competencies that?
>> Well, I can give my own.
I mean there's just a
huge number in fact
in some of my talks,
they give a long list
of challenges for AI.
It's not just that
you need symbols,
you need all sorts
of other things.
But I mean I think I'm going to
try to avoid your question
just because I
dabble in NLP but
certainly relations
and certainly a minimal
amount of first order things.
Certainly, the ability
to deal with hierarchies
and the ability to deal
with abstractions
at various levels.
I think we don't really know
what we really need yet.
So, I think it's like
someone who was able to,
the first people who had
gunpowder and could build
a very minimal rocket and
then could dream about going
to the moon someday, right?
We did go to the moon
some day but there was
a whole lot of other new concepts
that had to be
invented to actually
get there all
the way to the moon.
So, I think we're
leaving lots of problems
for the younger generation.
>> That's always good.
>> Even if a neural
net could take,
it can do Arabic to English
translation at 99 percent,
which I don't believe
that's going to happen,
it's going to really,
at that point,
be such a huge black box.
This is not healthy for
us to turn that over to
the next generation and
say, "Here, we're done.
We did natural
language translation."
They're not going
to be very happy
about that and they shouldn't be.
Let me just add one more point
because I don't want to
come across as
negative about this.
This is a great fact
that neural nets are
an amazingly good pattern
recognition class versus.
That also means you can use
these for real world problems.
>> Correct.
>> So, the fact
that we have okay,
but not particularly
good translation
means that I could probably
now take a device,
I could speak into it and
out would come bad Mandarin.
Therefore, I can walk around
in China and I can name it
actually like I could
have never had;
and that's good for me,
it's good for society, it's
good for humans that things
like that can be done. All right.
But it tends to lead into
people's minds way
further than that.
They think, "Well,
we've almost got
natural language
translation done,
bla bla bla bla, where
is that lead to?"
And the fact is "Well, we're
not even close to really.
We're like one percent of
really being able to do like
a human being can
do like a Shakespeare
can write Shakespeare",
but even like my 11 year old
can interact with his world
using natural language.
>> Eighteen-month olds
can interact
with their world in ways
that many of our current
systems can't do.
I want to read you
a quote from the AI.
>> I feel like I'm
suddenly in a courtroom.
>> No. No. No. This is
a good one I think.
>> Five years ago Mike,
you said this and now
you're saying that.
>> Just as humans
built buildings and
bridges before there
was civil engineering,
humans are processing
with the building of
societal scale inference
and decision
making systems that
involve machines,
humans and the environment.
Just this early building and
bridges sometimes fell to
the ground in unforeseen ways
with tragic consequences,
many of our early societal
scale inference and
decision making
systems are already exposing
serious conceptual flaws.
You look into the a little bit of
that in your previous comment,
but this really focuses on
these larger systems issues
and systems ways of thinking.
Can you comment on some
of that fragility?
How we're setting up people to
think about what's possible
and really what steps we need to
take to make progress
in some of these areas.
>> Yeah. So, I attempted in
this op-ed to give
Injaring the due respect
that it needs.
Injaring is not just a bunch of
nerds playing around with wires.
Injaring is really thinking
about how to make
the world a better place,
and how to make it a
little more predictable,
a little more
interesting and so on.
So, I have great respect
for people who did
civil engineering,
chemical engineering
in past generations.
My father was
a chemical engineer,
and they started with
chemical principles.
You blend these test tubes
together and out comes something,
and they went from there
all the way to be able
to put this together
in a factory.
They needed a huge raft
of principles to do that,
not just the basic chemistry
but all kinds of
mechanical things
and a range of other things
I know very little about.
That took decades to develop.
So, I think that that's
the thing that we're
talking about here,
but it's even a grandeur
thing we're talking
about bringing humans into
it in a very in central way;
and their utilities,
and their desires and
the conflicts or the corporation
that's involved there,
and we're talking
about data and so on.
So, when you start to do that,
you realize it's going
to be very much decades.
It's not going to emerge, AI is
not going to happen
in five years here,
and who cares if we get
systems that look like humans.
It's really about these systems.
So, in my op-ed, I try to come
up with very simple examples
of problems you might
think are already easily
solved or whatever but aren't.
So, provenance.
So, database people are
interested in a piece of data,
not just the piece of data
itself but where it came from.
Some metadata around it.
Who did it?
When was it done? And all that,
and that can be used helpfully in
various database systems
to make sure
something is coherent and
consistent and so on.
It's much, much worse when you
think about learning systems,
and data analysis, and
predictions and decisions.
So, I use an example
of medical data that
at any time you sit down
in front of a doctor,
they're going to think,
"Well, you've got
some weird symptoms here.
Have I ever seen
anything like that?"
And hopefully, they read
all the medical literature,
so they know all the data,
but maybe they don't, right?
But there's always not going
to be a particularly good match
between what they see in you and
your symptoms and others,
and maybe ideally there's
a really good match;
but in general,
what you're doing is you're
taking somewhat ill formed
ad hoc set of
observations that were
collected at a different place
in a different time,
in a different situation,
in a different context
and you're making
a judgment about how relevant
they are to
the current situation.
It's never going to be the case
that the current situation
just fits exactly
the data you collected
yesterday for
that particular
purpose, all right?
So, being able to
assess the relevance,
all that data is
actually irrelevant,
therefore the provenance of
that data is not relevant
to the situation,
therefore I cut
off my neural net.
I do not let it make
the inference that it
seems like it wants
to make, right?
I need to have my arrow bars
reflect that relevance
calculation.
Moreover, it's often going to be
the case that some data was
gathered at some place
in time and
it fed through many pathways,
and it comes in and to
us it looks like a bunch
of independent evidence,
and we say, "Well,
I'm seen 5,000 people were
saying this thing and it was
just that someone created
the rumor back when."
So, our political world
is full of this,
our journalistic world is
full of this and a lot of
false positives are happening.
People still don't understand
much about false discovery rate,
that your goal in
life shouldn't be
to make accuracy high.
It should make that relative
to the discoveries.
There's a denominator
and a numerator there.
Our current systems that do
neural nets and all
that are doing very,
very little with uncertainty.
They're doing very little
with what if questions.
with the kind of things
you need to have in
real intelligence system even if
it's not a super intelligence do.
In fact, they're doing
essentially nothing
with uncertainty,
and so huge gap.
So, that's kind of
the engineering discipline
needs to emerge.
It's not enough
just to know how to
put together basic ingredients
to build up a pattern
recognition system.
If that pattern recognition
system takes in
the symptoms of me in
the doctor's office and says,
"You need a heart operation."
I'm going to say, "What's
your air bar on that?
Are you sure? Is it
99 percent sure?
Where is that air bar
coming from?
Did you know a certain fact
about my family?
Do you know other facts
about me? Can we
think about this?
Can we get some more
data?" And so on.
Those are the things we
just can't do at all.
Forget even that we
can't mimic what
a five year old can do in
language and all that.
We can't do those competencies
about provenance,
about multiple decision making,
about uncertainty,
about and so on.
I just don't see enough people
talking about this stuff.
>> So, you're taking
a very systems level approach
to thinking about
this interesting new set of
emerging environments that blend
human computation and
machine computation.
What do you think
the right frameworks
for thinking about that are?
There's clearly a notion
of abstraction.
You talked about provenance.
The fact that we make
multiple decisions not
isolated decisions.
The fact that the world is not
IID by any stretch
of the imagination.
In fact, that's probably
the exception rather
than the rule.
How do you start
thinking from either a
theoretical or
an engineering perspective
about providing some
of those tools?
I know you have a little bit
of work in that area.
>> Yeah. Well, so,
I think we're going to need
a new Kolmogorov to emerge,
or a new Turin or
whatever to really,
really break open new things;
and whoever she is,
it's going to be
great. I can't wait.
But the best I can do in
my lifetime at least,
as I alluded to earlier,
is to not just look
within one discipline.
Not just think
that one to one technique,
and one way of thinking
is the right answer.
So, I do believe that
the vast scope of
inferential thinking,
of thinking about what's
out in the real world and
how to infer that from
the limited data I see,
including all the
sampling patterns that
might have gone into with
the biases that might arise.
Those are ideas that come
for 300 years of statistics.
It always pains me when
I see people that are
just or more
narrowly in the machine
learning world will say,
"Well, here's a new
problem, we've learned
about fairness before or bias."
Well, yes, people have.
So, if you take the vast scope
of inferential thinking,
and you put that together
with the slightly as vast,
but amazing computational era,
the last hundred years,
and the signal processing
control theory perspectives.
There's already some amazing
intellectual challenges
in trying to bring
those together.
Once you do, you get real power.
You can have systems
that can actually say,
in some sort of amount of
computational resources,
I can give you answers that are
trustable in
a computational sense,
but also I've got [inaudible].
Now to me, I actually think
in my last 15 years of my career,
and my last third let's say,
I'm going to do my best to bring
economic principles to bear
with these others as well.
So, you know, I do
think if you make
one decision or
a sequeled decision
that's kind of classical
AI statistics,
but if you have to
make, your system
has to make 100,000
decisions simultaneously,
no human being has to do that,
so we didn't evolve to do it.
But our system rigged
out to do that,
and so you need
a new kind of thinking.
So, economic thinking is not
about a single person and
their thinking style.
It's about large collections not
just of people, but
of other entities.
There has been work or
those algorithmic game theory,
there's econometrics
where these fields have
been brought together,
but as usual, in
very limited ways.
So, I believe if you bring
organizational thinking
and together with inferential
and computational,
already the challenge is immense,
and that's where we need to
face a lot these promises.
Of course, then, you're not done,
there's psychological,
and social,
and ethical, et cetera, etc.
But still, just this hard core
of a building systems that
are economically reasonable,
and the way they set
up incentives among
multiple components
of the system,
and that are able to
integrate humans,
that humans can have
transparency into them.
That they have statistical
solidity behind them,
not just in theirs
p-values or error bars,
but there's been
an appropriate sampling pattern
or has been a design-
>> Robust.
>> There's robust, and then
that these things
will work over time.
>> Yeah.
>> Like in the provenance
issue doesn't come
up if you're looking
at one time slice.
>> That' right.
>> Right? Provenance comes
up because the data
is out of date,
it was collected last year
in a different city and all that.
So, just talking all those
gets you both excited,
but also, I think it's daunting.
I think we have
a little bit too much hysteria
about how great everything
is were done.
I think the younger people
will maybe get this.
No, this is the beginning
and it's not a gold rush.
It's the start of
chemical engineering,
but you know to the power of 10.
It'll take decades and we engage,
roll up your sleeves and try to
make sure that we don't overhype,
and we don't get people
going crazy about things
like superhuman intelligence,
which is not going to happen.
>> Well, machines and humans
have complimentary skills.
>> They're complimentary.
That's, right.
>> I think a simpler level,
you're talking about
sort of massive systems
and massive scales and
hundreds of thousands of
interoperating parts.
>> But that's the real world
we're living already right now.
You think about
transportation systems, right?
That all these cars
are going around.
They're on these limited
resources called highways.
There is danger,
and there's issues.
So, if you put that into,
I mean Uber and Didi and
already do a limited
amount of this.
But you could easily
create congestion.
You can create troubles
if you don't kind of
think about the linked
set of decisions
that a group of
people have to make
and the system has to
do that quote, unquote.
That's could be partly human
and partly a computation.
>> There's a very
interesting world of I think
hybrid computation systems
that we don't know
a lot about the principles of.
Those systems are now
situated in a real world,
they're not just in a simulated
world or on a laboratory.
So, I think, as you point out,
there are just
immense challenges,
but also immense opportunities.
Let me ask you one last question.
You've had an amazing
set of students
over the last 20 or 30
years. I wrote some.
Here's for Ben Geow, David Blye,
Emily Fox, Zupan Ghahramani,
Thomas Hoffman, Tomioka Lo,
Percy Lang, Marina
Mallet, Andrew Aing,
Stender Singh, Alex Shane,
more recently we talked to,
I guess one of
your current students
Aisha Wilson is
joining the New York,
New England lab I guess.
>> Lester Mackey
is already there.
>> Lester Mackey is
already there, right?
Peter Bodik is already
here in Redmond.
What advice do you have
for the young students
getting involved in computer
science machine learning?
What should they study?
How should they get
out of, in many ways,
the rat race of climbing
up the leaderboard and
isolated problems?
>> You know, I don't have
any secrets about it.
Every year, I'm
amazed by how smart
these people are and
how enthusiastic,
entrepreneurial, and
progressive minded they are.
I get very, very
inspired by that.
I just try to look
with each person,
and kind of look at who they
are as an individual and
what they've got, and
what they're missing.
Get them to realize that it takes
five or six years to kind
of realize what they're
have inside of themselves.
I tend to encourage them
don't be in a rush.
Again, this is not a gold rush.
This is not your opportunity
to make money.
This is not
your opportunity to be
famous or whatever is your
opportunity to become a guru.
Your option is to
study and to actually
say something
meaningful and deep.
I'll just say what
everybody else is saying.
I try to get ahead of everybody.
But just, head off,
I often tell them
how often or I thought
go on one direction.
You see everybody going that way,
appreciate why they're
doing it and all that.
But appreciate also what
they're leaving and missing and
then go worthwhile and then
you can take your own time.
You can do it at your own pace.
You can have a lot
of comfort with
eventually when you
start to say things.
So, a lot of those great students
who really have done
some great things.
They have published
a small handful of papers.
Not all of them are
some kind of examples
who publish way more
than they should have.
But a few of them published
a small handful of papers,
but they were deep papers
and it was a pleasure
to be able to
write about how they really
solved a big challenge.
Aisha Wilson, [inaudible] theory
for continuous dynamical systems
that do optimization.
Lester Mackey did this amazing
work on Stein's method,
applied the matrix concentration
even though it was
not at all his area,
it was an orthogonal cut in
the space that he was taking.
He spent a year or
two working on it,
something beautiful came out.
A handful of those kind
of things and people
pay attention.
This is someone who
could actually think in
new ways and help
us to move along.
I guess the other point
I want to make is that I
loved all my students
partly because of how
great their minds were,
but also how friendly and
fun they were to be around.
So, when I pick students,
it's kind of enthusiasm and
love of abstraction,
of mathematical ideas,
of trying understand deeply,
but also humility about
each one of our own role
in this and how we,
being in a social environment
and connecting to each other.
It's the best way for all
of us to work and it's fun.
So, I've had a
particularly social group.
They've all made
friends with each
other and made friends
with them too.
I feel very connected
not just to them,
but to a lot of other
researchers out in the world.
I do travel around in Europe,
in China, and other places a lot,
and I easily find myself
kind of in grief, you know,
getting involved
in people's lives
there and how they think
and what they do
because I think we
all are really sharing
a lot of this.
So, I do very much resist
the AI is because
she is going to be
done in this country or that
country, sort of thing, and all.
It's really about trade,
and it's really about shared
understanding and
shared development.
I think that the younger
people just get that.
So, as long as we
kind of encourage
them that you don't have
to give up on that,
that you can build a career
that is based on sincerity,
honesty, and study, and you can.
That their natural strengths
come right out.
>> I love the reflections on
this being giving
people space to grow,
not feeling like
they have to publish
10 MIPS papers in a year.
Doing it as part of
a larger intellectual community.
When I think back
on the PDP days,
there was that sense of
energy and excitement.
I love those reflections.
For new students in
thinking about how to
get into these areas
and to make progress.
Part of it is to slow down,
take a broader perspective
and surround yourself
in an environment where
you can share ideas,
share nascent ideas, and work
together to come up to
some great solution, so.
>> Yeah. Microsoft is
a great, I really,
over the years continue to be
amazed by how stable it's been,
as a kind of an electoral
source in the world.
I see Microsoft as kind of
returning to the fore right now.
Just to give a little plug that
now I've been here three
times this summer.
I think it's really kind of watch
the space of IT development
throughout the world,
and it said there's
a role we can play
and it's sort of
a almost a senior citizen.
But bring trust back to how
IT interacts with the world.
I think that's one of
the big agenda items.
I think it's being embraced here.
I'm real pleased about that.
So, the academic
industry relation is
very healthy and Microsoft is
helping lead that
as we go forward.
>> I mean for us and for
the rest of the industry,
I think we need to nurture
that kind of students that you
and others are developing
and do that together.
There are lots of things
that folks experience in
industry that they may or
may not in universities.
So, I think it's
a beautiful synergy.
>> Indeed. I agree.
>> Thanks for being
a part of that with us.
>> All right, thank you.
>> Okay.